good evening my name is David Peters and
I'm a senior at Hillsdale College
majoring in accounting and today I have
the distinct pleasure to introduce to
you our speaker for tonight
PJ or work PJ O'Rourke an author and
political humorist was born in Toledo
Ohio and received degrees from Miami
University in Oxford Ohio and Johns
Hopkins University mr. Burke has served
as editor in chief of National Lampoon
as foreign affairs desk chief at Rolling
Stone and as a correspondent for the
Atlantic in the fall of 2010 he was the
Eugene C pulling him visiting fellow in
journalism at Hillsdale College a former
board member of Freedom House he is
currently a contributing editor for the
Weekly Standard an HL Mencken fellow at
the Cato Institute and a regular
panelist on the National Public national
public radio program wait wait don't
tell me he is the author of many books
including on The Wealth of Nations
Parliament of horrors give War a chance
and thrown under the omnibus a reader
please welcome PJ O'Rourke
thank you thank you it is it's always a
great pleasure and a great honor to be
here at Hillsdale Hillsdale it's just
magnificent center of clear-thinking
a rare Center of clear thinking the only
problem being I'm not a very clear
thinker so thus it is when I stand up to
speak at Hillsdale along with the great
pleasure in the great honor comes a
certain great trepidation that I am in
fact too stupid to be speaking to you
but in fairness to myself I'm not just
stupid I am a student of stupidity I am
a political reporter I may not be
qualified to speak to you about anything
intelligent but I am perfectly qualified
to speak to you about this election we
we live in a democracy ruled by the
people 50% of people are below average
in intelligence mathematical fact and
that explains everything
about the 2016 presidential election and
by the way I am full of righteous
indignation about this election because
I'm a political satirist in this
election is fully self satirizing I am a
political humorist and I cannot be
funnier than Hillary's pantsuits and I
am a political commentator and I can't
get a word in edgewise with Donald Trump
interrupting all the time so I'm not
only full of righteous indignation I'm
unemployed so the 2016 presidential
election we started out with about a
about a hundred and ten presidential
candidates who were these Jack legs
these high binders wire pullers monta
banks well heads Buncombe spigots butl
artists for flushers and animated
spittoons offering themselves as worthy
of America's highest office I mean they
they they take us voters for fools oh
yeah of course they did but but were
they also deluded were they also insane
were they receiving radio broadcasts on
their dental fillings telling them that
they would be a good president I mean
finally I think rather heroically we the
American public narrowed it down to five
Cruz Clinton Kasich Sanders and Trump
that's not a list of presidential
candidates that's the worst law firm in
the world that's that's a that's a law
firm that couldn't get Caitlyn Jenner
off on a charge of Bruce Jenner identity
theft I mean
I'll see as the office of the presidency
hasn't diminished in stature until it
attracts only the leprechauns of public
life or have our politicians shrunk
until none of them can pass the carnival
test you must be taller than a clown too
to run for president you know back when
this all began it seemed as if the two
candidates would inevitably be Jeb Bush
and Hillary Clinton and I trembled for
my country because members of the
electorate would go into the voting
booth and they would see the names Bush
and Clinton and they would think to
themselves gosh I'm getting forgetful I
I I did this already and they leave
without marking the ballot you know
voter turnout would be 6% yeah I mean
the shuttle from the local old-age home
would send a few senile Republicans to
the polls a Democratic National
Committee bus would collect some
derelicts from Skid Row and and we would
have the first President of the United
States elected by a franchise limited to
sufferers from Alzheimer's disease in
drunken bombs man what happened to Jeb
Bush I mean Jeb had at all he's young
for a Republican a Phi Beta Kappa a
successful businessman and a former
governor of Florida were baoding
incompetence and corruption are vital to
the GOP plus he was rolling like a dirty
dog in campaign contributions you know
and then it just all went wrong you know
and it turned out that even Hillary
Clinton didn't have a lock on her
nomination as she she faced a challenge
from of all people the the screwy
kablooie commander of the Vermont Kong
Bernie Sanders you know Bernie's a
socialist he says so no I mean not you
know that may be fine in some parts of
the world where there used to socialists
you know but but in America you say
you're a socialist you know that means
the Geiss is saying it's okay to steal
stuff you know yeah and Bernie is I mean
Bernie I mean you know he not only says
it's okay he thinks it's like you know a
blessing Bernie believes it's wiping
your flat-screen TV and giving it to a
family of pill addicts in the backwoods
of Vermont is a good deed you know
Bernie Bernie claims he wants to make
America more like Europe great idea
because you're upset a swell track
record for for like a hundred years now
you know I mean ever since Archduke
Ferdinand's car got a flat in Sarajevo
in 1914 yeah make America more like
Europe or to even go to get all the
Nazis and commies and 90 million dead
people that it would take to make
America more like Europe and yet and yet
you can see what Bernice appeal was
compared to Hillary I mean Hillary
carries more baggage than the Boeing she
used as Secretary of State visiting
every country that later blew up in her
face in a request to fulfill the mission
of the US Secretary of State which is to
accumulate frequent flier miles
she had Julian Assange set up her State
Department email server she she put the
Dalai Lama on security duty at the US
consulate in Benghazi geopolitical
conflicts of interest at the Clinton
Foundation they are so large they have
to be weighed on Chris Christie's
bathroom scale
and and at any moment any moment that
ferret of a husband of hers might might
slip his leash and get up to old pants
tricks running up the running up the
pant legs of young interns I mean now on
the upside let's be fair on the upside
Hillary is familiar with the White House
she knows where the extra toilet paper
is stored and where the spare key to the
nuke missile launch briefcase is hidden
which is on the Truman balcony it's the
second pillar from the left and this
leases with Donald Trump so I'm
supporting Donald Trump I'm supporting
Donald Trump because of something the
great political satirist HL Mencken said
Menken said democracy is the theory that
the common people know what they want
and deserve to get it good and hard
Trump's Trump's chief domestic policy
goal will be to be on TV and you know as
president Trump will get to be on TV all
the time 24/7 but this might not be so
bad because just spraying his hair
during commercial breaks should keep
Trump too busy to push any other
birdbrain domestic policy goals and
Trump can yell you're fired all you
wants and it will make for a healthy
turnover in Trump cabinet appointees
such as Dennis Rodman Larry King and
Vince McMahon Plus Trump understands the
American economy he'll grow America's
economy the same way he grows own with
bad debt bad debt bad debt bad debt and
more bad debt you know I mean America's
average household debt right now is more
than two hundred and twenty-five
thousand dollars Trump Trump Trump has
restructured 3.5 billion of his business
debt and 900 million of his personal
debt restructured being the Trump way of
saying that he didn't pay it and we
Americans know a leader when we see one
then imagine Trump's foreign policy now
here's a guy who's under the illusion
that he's about ten times richer than he
actually is
who believes President Obama was born in
carjacked a stand to the Queen of Sheba
and raised by Islamist wolves in the
remote forests of Harvard Law School
which which last part may be true now
Russia China Iran Isis the Taliban and
Hamas will be paralyzed with fear
because who knows what this lunatic is
gonna do well what he'll do is build
hundreds of Trump casinos Trump hotels
and Trump resorts in Moscow Beijing
Tehran Raqqa Kandahar and the Gaza Strip
then all of them will go bankrupt the
way Trump Taj Mahal Trump Plaza Hotel
and Trump Entertainment Resorts did
Trump's gonna leave Russia trying to
Palm off the eastern Ukraine on angry
bondholders and in China auctioning
distressed property in the Spratly
Islands you know I mean hell this might
work
let's let's try and look on the bright
side uh-uh-uh-uh-uh of the 2016
presidential election maybe maybe this
election is a teachable moment you know
I mean because really when our members
of both political parties going to learn
that politics
it's a railroad that runs both ways in
the politicians keep creating this
powerful huge heavy gigantic unstoppable
freight train of a government and then
they get all shocked and scared and weep
you and it looks like somebody they
detest such as Donald Trump such as
Hillary Clinton might get a hold of the
throttle turn the train around and run
them over with it you know I mean make
the train smaller make it a little
engine that could you know I mean then
you won't have so much trouble getting
off the tracks when it comes slowly
huffing and puffing towards you while
your SUV full of rights and liberties is
stalled on the railroad grade crossing
you know I'm a libertarian I'm a
libertarian well maybe maybe not a
capital L libertarian I'm not really a
capital L libertarian cuz I can't say
that the libertarian party is making the
kind of impact that you would expect in
an election where the two major
candidates are so unpopular that they
seem to be engaged in a competition to
see who can get unfriended most on
Facebook I mean I like Gary Johnson I
like Bill weld
I wouldn't surprise myself if I ended up
voting for them but but Johnson does
seem as if maybe he not only legalized
but also utilized a certain recreational
substance and also he thinks Aleppo is a
brand of dog food and and I'm not at all
sure what the former like moderate
Republican governor of Massachusetts is
doing on a libertarian slate I mean but
but Bill well he does like to have a
good time and maybe running for vice
president gets him invited to more
cocktail parties so Gary Johnson and
Bill weld I think of it as the toke and
tipple ticket
anyway as I was saying I'm a libertarian
you know and that means I want all
politics to go away and I subscribe to
the libertarian political philosophy and
the main thing to understand about the
libertarian political philosophy is that
it's not a political philosophy it's an
anti political philosophy libertarians
don't want to fix politics well I take
that back we do want to fix politics the
way you fix a cat the way you the way
you spay a dog the way you the way you
castrate a dangerous ball you know we
mean to tame these political sob so
we're gonna teach them not to beg at the
table teach them not to bark at the moon
teach them to quit licking each other's
you know what I mean you know I'm gonna
teach politicians to heal gonna teach
politicians to come when they're called
more important we're gonna teach them
the meaning a down boy and on we're
gonna we're gonna watch them scurry away
with their tails between their legs when
we yell get you know we're gonna teach
politicians domestic policy stay off the
furniture you know no politics on my bed
we're gonna teach some foreign policy
stop making messes on other people's
lawns we're gonna teach them to roll
over and play dead because we're gonna
teach them term limits you know when we
toss our political power to a politician
that politician is gonna bring our
political power right back here and drop
it at our feet and good boy and now get
back in the kennel or such at least is
the hope of every libertarian a faint
hope perhaps and at best those goals are
going to take a long time to achieve but
you would think that an election like
this would be some kind of lesson in
libertarianism or not or not I mean we
have to consider what has caused what
has caused us to have such awful people
as our only two presidential options
it's not something that's just happening
in America it's part of a larger problem
I mean we are in the midst of a global
revolt against the elites the elites who
created the post
war to international order and who for
the past 70 years have been running
everything running everything into the
ground as far as a libertarian is
concerned now the hallmarks of the lead
of the elites has been the expansion of
collectivist political power political
power it has expanded in size and
expense I mean one-third of the world's
GDP is now spent by the politicians in
governments one out of every three
things you make is grabbed by
governments if your cat has three
kittens one of them is a government
agent the political power has expanded
in scope politics casts its net over
every little aspect of life nothing is
so private that it isn't tangled up in
politics I mean in America the latest
thing has been transgender bathrooms now
we all know politics is crap now we find
out that where we take one is a
political issue you know in people all
over the world are saying we're sick of
the elites we're sick of the supposed
experts the so-called authorities the
self-appointed know-it-alls
we're tired of people who think they
know what's best for us better than we
do you know now we can see this revolt
against the elites in we can see it in
the brexit vote in Britain we can see it
in the rise of alternative and and EU
skeptic political parties in Europe we
can see it in Brazil where almost every
politician in the country has been
charged with corruption for the simple
reason that they're guilty of it we can
see the the revolt against the elites of
course in the spectacle of Donald Trump
but we also have to look at his opponent
I mean a nasty fight between the elites
and the anti elites brings forth the
worst from both sides
you know elites are bossy preachy smug
domineering self-righteous self
impressed self-serving and selfish and
Hillary Clinton is their queen now
yes means I don't drop maybe a rich guy
a member of the 1% but there's nothing
elite about him I mean there's not
nothing nothing a leader what about the
way he sounds you know he sounds like
the rest of us unfortunately he sounds
like the rest of us after we've had a
few drinks but he sounds like you know I
mean Trump may be a jerk but you can
imagine playing around a golf with Trump
I mean I have it on good authority that
he doesn't you know cheat any worse than
the rest of us do but imagine a round of
golf with Hillary she's got 20 Harvard
Graduate caddies who've read a lot of
books about golf but I've never been on
the links they spend the whole match
telling you not her what club to use a
Secret Service is there to make sure you
take that suggestion do you know take
hit hit from the fairway with a sand
wedge after your chip shot the cup and
the pin somehow get moved closer to
Hillary's lie by what what an apposite
word to use in any game that Hillary's
involved in and the scorecard
mysteriously winds up on Hillary's
personal email server any libertarian
can understand the revolt against the
elites but but what libertarians have to
face up to is that the revolt against
the elites is not actually advancing
libertarian values the revolt is not
producing an increase in individual
dignity and increase in individual
liberty and increase in individual
responsibility in fact it said a
tendency to produce the opposite I mean
Trump vowing to build a wall between
individual dignity in the United States
many of the rising alternative EU
skeptic parties in Europe are
nationalistic chauvinistic even outright
racist and based on a fear and
detestation of the refugees fleeing to
Europe from the Middle East
demon chaos you know fear is not
irrational the elites failed to address
the root causes of the Middle East demon
chaos indeed the elites seemed to have
been breeding demons and in the kennels
of elite diplomatic and military
strategy in the Middle East and then
turning those deem
loose in the Middle East as if demons
had ever been an endangered species in
the Middle East as if the elites were
trying to reintroduce them in him and
one result of these elite failures has
been murder all over the world I mean
how much farther away from the quarrels
and hatreds of the Middle East could a
person get than to be at Lattin night in
a gay nightclub in Orlando Florida
you know another result has been the
refugee crisis in Europe I mean the
elites deletes don't care refugees
aren't crowding the halls and jostling
the elites in the European Parliament
you know the refugees aren't building
their shacks on the tennis courts that
the elites private clubs you know the
growing populist hatred of refugees it's
a libertarian tragedy elites are
refusing to address the cause of this
integration and populist anti elites are
refusing to accept the effects result is
to say it's an across-the-board
crackdown on immigration immigrants are
simply being dumped in refugee camps in
squatter shanty towns in it and if they
have managed to make it across the
border in slums
not only is it is populist hatred of
these refugees a libertarian tragedy
populism itself is a libertarian tragedy
since the beginning of democracy in
Athens in the 5th century BC the
greatest danger to democratic
institutions has always been the demos
the people themselves the very item that
constitutes democracy it's like
democracy doesn't contain the seeds of
its own destruction it contains the
roots the fruits and a whole damn tree
you know each person in a democracy is
of course an individual the way we
libertarians say that each person is but
when the persons become the people and
the people become populist you watch out
I mean I mean what do you think would
have happened if that charming old bloke
Socrates lovable eccentric full of silly
questions had gone around Athens
personally asking each Athenian should I
be condemned to death
I mean individuals would never have
killed Socrates they had to become a mob
first and what always comes to the fore
in a mob mobsters the so called all
right in KKK robes or less comically
marine lepen and France or or tragically
Vladimir Putin populist champion of the
revolt against the crooked and foolish
elites of post-soviet Russia there are
populist elements in the neo mile ISM of
Xi Jinping
is using it to root out corruption using
that as his excuse for oppression their
populist aspects to to to Islamic
terrorism itself a fanatical
interpretation of Eid of jihad was was
first and foremost a rebellion against
certain Muslim elites elites who were
and are Saddam Hussein Hussein Emaar
barik Muammar Qaddafi Bashar al-assad
pigs just pigs you know the populism
seeks the cohesion of individuals into a
collective group a social class and
ethnicity and identity with its own
identity politics and this is inimicable
to every libertarian principle
individual dignity is in an individual
quality there is no such thing as group
dignity you know and what is group
freedom it sounds like the kind of
freedom drug gangs on the southside of
Chicago on you know and group
responsibility collective responsibility
we know what that is that's what what
that's the way Palestinian extremists
regard every Israeli the way Israeli
extremists regard every Palestinian you
know the West Bank that's a great model
for a society but exactly why why isn't
a revolt against the elites teaching a
libertarian lesson I mean we should be
learning the value of individual freedom
from the failure of the elites and the
fiasco of their vast collective
political power good things are made by
free individuals in free association
with other free individuals and notice
that's how we make babies
individual freedom of us about bringing
things together politics is about
dividing things up you know elites would
have us make babies by putting the woman
over on this side of the room and the
men over on that side of the room
and while the elites stand in the middle
taxing sperm and eggs but we are we are
learning lessons in individual freedom
basically because the world is such a
scary place right now we're faced with
frightening speed of technological
change worrisome economic instability
we're faced with violent fanaticism and
fear is a bad school marm we have got a
monster at the blackboard
knockin kids learn even 2+2 if all I can
think is the teachers huge and slimy and
scaly and has three heads you know so we
turn for help to the big stupid bullies
in the back of the room and that would
be Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump we
don't know who else to turn to
which is another reason why we're not
getting a libertarian lesson I mean
libertarianism depends upon civil
society and lately our society just
hasn't been so civil but more to the
point the expansion of public politics
leaves little room for private
Association our community organizations
our clubs are lodges fellowships
Brotherhood's our union halls and our
churches are no longer playing important
roles in the drama of civics they have
been upstaged by politics politics has
become such an obese operatic performer
warbling so loudly that none of us bit
players can be heard and politics is so
fat that we are shoved into the
orchestra pit it is over when the fat
lady sings I mean every grievance no
matter how minor such as the speed of
our internet connections results in a
political demonstration now this was not
always so the abolition of slavery in
the British Empire was largely a private
social enterprise the abolition movement
was started in the 18th century by
Quakers who had limited political
influences as dissenters they weren't
eligible to stand for Parliament the
abolition movement drew its strongest
support from from from women and and the
Industrial Revolution
working-class they had no political
influence British franchise was still
limited by property qualifications and
women didn't have the vote at all and
yet abolition prevailed not only were
all the slaves in the British Empire
freed but the British Navy fought the
slave trade everywhere else in the world
all because of community organizations
clubs lodges and fellowships and this is
I mean it's amazing this is like saying
my bowling league cured Zika you know
well could be done you know if you get
more research scientists to learn how to
bowl you know or let Hillsdale College
be your bowling league you know it can
cause a little discouragement being a
libertarian not that we are discouraged
great people don't get discouraged it
takes a lot of bravery being a
libertarian bravery to be logical in the
face of the absurd informed in the face
of ignorance right in the face of wrong
we few we happy few we band of brothers
and sisters populace at home in bed with
their bad political ideas shall think
themselves accursed they were not here
tonight libertarians always have to
accept the fact that politically
libertarianism is a hard sell people
people want easy answers there are
intelligent answers there are correct
answers there are even obvious answers
but politically there are no easy
answers libertarians say elect us and we
will do less for you
not about Gutter you know never mind
that less is often the very thing that
needs doing most because libertarianism
is a hard sell there's an abiding the
temptation among libertarians to retreat
into the apolitical and you know given
what politics has been like these days a
political it's got a nice ring to it
but but in fact there's no such thing as
a political politics is like gravity
there's no getting away from it on this
planet now it's fine to have no opinion
about gravity or to love it when it
keeps the baby in the crib or and hate
it when you step on the bathroom scale
but you can't ignore it you know maybe
you're a progressive libertarian you
know --left libertarian and you need
gravity to keep your head full of Spacey
anarchist ideas from floating away maybe
you're a conservative libertarian a
free-market Liberty
toreen and you need gravity so that you
can shove the competition to the ground
you know but you can't pretend gravity
doesn't exist and you can't pretend that
politics doesn't exist either that's
that's the same as stepping into thin
air from a 40th storey window you know
specifically a 40th storey window and
Trump Plaza libertarianism is a
political philosophy that fundamentally
opposes politics is necessary for
libertarians to engage with politics
politics is the question of an
individual's relationship to a society
the question of an individual's
relationship to society is a bad
question it's a bad question and to
judge by most politics past and present
the question has a bad answer for
individuals libertarianism exists to
change the answer and the question
individuality is a fact politics is an
intellectual abstraction a way of
thinking about persons collectively as
if a bunch of people were a single thing
the populist cohesion of individuals
into a group the people the nation the
state politics is imaginary
never mind that this fictitious concept
can cause oppression slaughter war and
occasionally benefits imagination is
powerful individuals alas are not so
powerful but individuals aren't
fictitious every individual is actual
with actual needs and wants actual joys
and sorrows actual freedoms and
responsibilities people are real
politics is an idea there are names for
the kind of thing thinking that regard
ideas as more important than people one
of those names would be Paul Pott
individuals do not in fact have a real
relationship with politics individuals
have a real relationship only with other
individuals now of course there may be a
lot of individuals with whom we have
that relationship for example we in this
room we probably would not pledged Our
Lives our Fortunes our sacred honor to
some hairbrained collectivist political
idea of a society but we would hope
willingly risk all that for the reality
of the 320 million into
Jules who live in America however no one
and by no one I mean the populace in
revolt against the elites around the
world specifically no one should let
this willingness to sacrifice mislead
them into notions of political
collectivism when the ancient Hebrews
rebelled and they rebelled against the
bondage of the Egyptian elite they they
no doubt regarded themselves as a people
a nation a state a cohesive end of a
cohesion of individuals into a
collective group God said nope God said
nope and God gave the Hebrews a timeout
and when he gave him a timeout he
delivered his Ten Commandments and every
one of those Commandments was a
commandment to the individual you the
specific individual you you shalt do
this you shalt not do that I'm talking
to you no group discounts closest God
comes to mentioning the populists idea
of a cohesive collective group is the
tenth commandment when he forbids the
Hebrews from practicing collectivism God
said thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's wife nor manservant his
maidservant nor socks nor zas don't said
God goes staking a claim on other
people's asses mind your own okay that's
that's everything I know but if anybody
has
if anybody has any questions I'll make
up some other stuff okay so we have the
mic bearers here and they will go around
and hand the mic to people they've done
so already
thank you ma'am all right coming here
tonight I've enjoyed your books in the
past and it was obvious you were very
liberal in your younger days and you
sort of followed the observation I guess
of Winston Churchill that if you are not
liberal when you're young you have no
heart and if you're not conservative
when you're older you have no brain is
there any one thing that changed you
from a liberal path to a more
conservative yes there's definitely a
change I mean yeah I followed the I'm a
child of the 60s I followed the
zeitgeist sixties but we should always
all remember us older people in the
audience should remember to always be a
little forgiving of kids for being
left-wing because there's this idea in
Marxism and Lenin stated it specifically
that from each according to his ability
to each according to his need now we all
know that's rubbish it absolutely
doesn't work except for one place where
is the one place that that actually
works the family right the family and
what do kids know about where is their
whole model for like political construct
is the check from dad that comes every
month you know so of course they're
lefties you know tell me what happened
to me of us I eventually got a job you
know I got a job I got a job for a
hundred and fifty dollars a week we got
paid every two weeks and I was really
looking forward to that $300 and so was
my landlord and I and then I got a check
but I got my first paycheck and I'd net
it out at like one 7995 after federal
tax and state tax and city tax and
Social Security and health care plan
contributions and union dues and this
that netted out and I go wait a minute
I'm a communist I've demonstrated for
communism I protested for communism up
vandalized for commie not rioted for
communism I finally get a
with a big capitalist corporation and I
find out we've got communism already
they just took half my money yeah I'm
not rockefeller so yeah it changed
things pretty quickly ma'am
trying to have a personal vendetta
against I don't want to vote free there
one of those people and I wonder what
the chances are if we could get more
people just to vote just to keep one of
them from getting 50% more than 50%
you know I unfortunately is this is
going to be a situation to be endured
not avoided it's really impossible now
you know you would have thought that the
libertarian party that this would be a
tremendous moment for them I don't know
why they put in such a underly
lackluster but even throwing it into the
house is just going to give it to the
Republicans to decide and they will
decide for there really is no way around
we're gonna have one or the other of
these people and about the only thing we
can do is get prepared the problem here
is of course with Trump I don't know
what to prepare for exactly the problem
with Hillary is I know exactly what to
prepare for you know it's an awful awful
decision and I personally am hoping that
you live in you know here in the Midwest
you're all in swing states probably
everybody in this room is a voter in a
swing state and our a potentially a
swing state and I live in New Hampshire
which is also a swing state so it's like
our individual one little vote might
actually matter you know Anessa I don't
want that rigged kind of responsibility
I'm just hoping that somebody is 20%
ahead when on ballot day in my state in
New Hampshire and so I can go in and
tick off Gary Johnson and let him find
out Aleppo on his own
sure so much for your time today and
coming out and giving us a lecture so my
question is gonna focus on the
intersection between what you mentioned
about group dignity and then the
libertarian movement so when I'm curious
about one is first of all if there's no
such thing as group dignity then what is
it saying libertarian movement by
definition of paradox of sorts or
contradiction and then furthermore
secondly if there's no such thing as
group dignity in terms of a political
movement rightly so then how do how do
libertarians actually make their case
for these ideals of free markets and
these ideals of individual liberty that
they so hope to which I'm sorry you guys
slow down a little it's not last part I
got the first part right so how do
libertarians make their case as for
those ideas that they all hold thing
about libertarianism as a political
party does turn out to be paradoxical
and also ineffective as we have seen and
I asked Rand Paul about this I know
Randall but I've interviewed a couple
times we've had some long talks and he
said you know the thing in coach the ran
should know you know because whose dad
his you know but about libertarians he
said the thing with libertarians is too
rigidly logical they're very very much
they believe in logic and they're very
logical when they approach issues and
they are so logical that they completely
convinced themselves that they are
utterly and absolutely right and there
some there there much more right than
anybody else including all the other
libertarians and he said you know what
happens is there's so much logic flying
around if you put two libertarians in
room you get three positions yeah
and it just really what libertarianism
is in in in in at its heart it's an
attitude it's a measure it's not not
even an attitude it's a measuring sticks
yardstick in what libertarian does is in
any person any policy any political
party it measures it asks three
questions does this does this increase
human liberty does it increase human
dignity does it increase
human responsibility that's the third
one that's that that's the part that
that you always kind of want to forget
about you know like the responsibility
part can I just have the liberty and
dignity no no you have to get the
responsibility too so libertarianism is
really a lens to look at things through
more than it's not an ideology per se
it's it's it's it's a measuring stick
sir
HL Mencken yes said if voting made any
difference they wouldn't let us do it
now you are the HL Mencken something or
other why isn't the conclusion of your
talk that we shouldn't vote at all the
whole country should protest and say we
are not voting this yeah well I mean
again it's a tempting position no I I
think Menken had that a little wrong if
voting mattered they wouldn't let us do
it for free
we'd have to buy our votes the way the
Democratic Party does yeah I think they
are good at that I don't
darris there there there are three good
reasons to vote
he is loathsome so you can vote against
him she's detestable so you could vote
against her and or you can you know put
the third party but really the most
important vote is down ballot this is
the real reason doesn't matter what you
know we're gonna get a bad deal no
matter what the outturn in the
presidential race is we have to have I
know the Republicans have not been very
effective I know they have not been like
the kind of purists that they claim to
be I know that this sort of idea free
but they do act as a brake on on wild
Democratic huge expansions of government
and entitlement programs it's extremely
important that we have a Democratic
House of Representatives and a
Democratic Senate to stop
not because what they will do but what
they can stop from happening so what's
that oh did I know again yeah well they
stink too no it's very important that we
have a Republican House of
Representatives in a Republican Senate
and because just just because of their
braking power not because of anything
good that they will do ma'am thank you
for bringing humor to the other side of
the looking glass for all of us
there is something that's not down
ballot that's important and that's the
Supreme Court well yeah this is like I
have a lot of trouble with Trump as you
can probably tell but I gotta say that
who gets appointed to the Supreme Court
is a worry were very very worrisome
thing and I wish I had a little bit more
reliable view of you know I wish I I
wish I felt he were a little more
trustworthy about who he would actually
appoint but it is a strong pro-trump
argument there are other strong
prototype arguments I mean I don't like
the guy but I'm not I'm not deaf to the
arguments for him and I don't I don't
despise other people who are going to
decide to vote for him the one of the
strongest was from a very good friend of
mine who's on the Wall Street Journal's
editorial board and a man I respect
enormously a very good Catholic and with
a big family of adopted children from
from from bad places around the world
kids who really needed to be adopted
great guy he said every president brings
a few thousand people in the office with
him or her not just the appointees of
but but all the hangers-on you know and
all the campaign staff and their friends
and in journalism and the influencers
and the influenced and so on it's a big
comic trail every president brings these
several thousand people in with him he
said people that Trump brings in may be
terrible names they may be utter bums
and get up to all sorts of mischief and
cheat on their expense accounts and
behave like idiots he said but the
people that Hillary Clinton is going to
bring in every single one of them hates
me personally hates my religion
hates my values and wants to take my
money every single one of them that is a
strong argument and of course that
concludes the Supreme Court you know I
mean that's as part of that dirty Comet
trail that Hillary will bring in with
her okay we have any more questions out
there we do thank you for being here
tonight I describe myself as massively
libertarian in this election has been
sort of disappointing to me due to the
current canons we have to offer how does
the libertarian party move forward from
this election and become a popular party
that people do not vote simply as a
protest but vote because they agree with
the ideals that it presents well I don't
think there's much hope for the
Libertarian Party it's been around for a
long time it's been around since 1970 or
71 there's never made any significant
impact I think that libertarians I mean
maybe there is maybe it may be one of
the political parties I'm guessing the
GOP will fall apart at the end of this
but and will be time for another party
but we got to remember political parties
are not really very American American
doesn't really have political parties we
have a pair of Venda it's a Venn diagram
we have tendency we have political
tendency we political parties like
they've got in Europe have ideologies
they have you have membership cards
they've got dues you can be expelled
from them you know they vote to see who
their leader will be et cetera so we
don't do that we don't do that we just
have two general tendencies you know you
got like the stupid party in the silly
party you know I like I said I'm stupid
so I vote for the stupid party the
Republicans you know then over there you
got the silly party and one you know one
this is kind of like dumb and leave me
alone and the other one is like
government can fix everything you know
and it's and those tendencies often have
quite a bit of overlap as they did
during the 50s and and even up until in
the 60s up until Goldwater ran for
president
I was parties often overlap quite a bit
and sometimes they get so they're just a
Venn diagram two circles in a Venn
diagram or barely touching libertarians
have got to realize that Americans like
vote according to like broad tendency
not according to like a specific like
line of of rigid reasoning a certain
sort of ideology which as I pointed out
before
libertarians themselves can't agree on
you know let alone get all of us to
agree with them you know a party really
has to be it has to be a big tent in the
United States a political party has to
be a big tent you know you can lure
everybody into the tent with bribes the
way the Democrats do you know or you can
lure them into the tent with promises
the way the Republicans do but it has to
be a big tent sir yeah number of years
ago read that you felt that Scandinavian
socialism works that what that
Scandinavian or Swedish socialism works
yeah still believe that oh yeah to an
extent I mean this isn't socialism in
the Scandinavian countries does work
pretty well the reason is that the
countries are tiny and the people are
all alike so if you set up a government
system where that takes a lot of your
resources away from you and then gives
you a lot of benefits that works okay if
you if everybody agrees on what those
benefits are if you know if you got free
grad school that's great in Scandinavian
countries because everybody goes to grad
school you know so it works fine now
that these countries are becoming more
diverse it's working less and less well
but I mean it's a you know every time
they talk about the the marvel of the
Nordic systems they're forgetting how
tiny and diverse these countries are
they're not a fit model for a gigantic
country like ours the other thing is we
don't have there is no Nash there is no
mission to America America's mission is
for everybody to get a chance to try to
do what they want to do as long as it
doesn't like physically injure other
people who are trying to do it they want
to do you know so I mean this is America
doesn't have a purpose America is not a
nationality America is a set of
practices and beliefs and and so there's
useless models the other thing was
there's something else I was gonna say
about that
oh yeah it's Milton Friedman there's
also you know when you have like a very
cohesive group of people who are all
alike they tend to have similar
characteristics and so once Milton
Friedman was argued
with a Swedish politician a Swedish
politician saying incedent we have no
poverty Milton Friedman said that's
interesting because among Swedes in
America we've got no poverty either yeah
who else have we got the movie Lincoln
when I first watched it I didn't quite
understand a lot of nuances in the
script so I went to the internet and
downloaded the script and read it and
one of the recurring themes in the
script is how Lincoln felt that the
office of the presidency changed him how
he had a mold himself to the presidency
could you speculate we'll postulate a
trump victory could you could you
project into the future and kind of
determine if Trump will change the
office or the office will change Trump I
think the office is a pretty big
important mold and I think the office
will probably change him I would be my
hope that the office would change him we
are not working with the same raw
materials as we were with Lincoln we do
have to remember that
who else have we got here yes yes sir
given your your proposition that
libertarian isn't more an attitude than
perhaps a party where do you see the
hope or the course for increasing our
cultural focus on the individual when
our our education system has such a
stranglehold on the bribery that the
Left seems to live by you know the truth
of the matter is as I get older I get
more pessimistic it's just it happens to
us all I think is that the tendency in
America and and generally in Western
democracies has been a you know an
ever-expanding size and scope and
expense of government and that what's
going to have to happen is is a crisis
it's going to have to be it's gonna have
to work so badly it's not gonna go away
until it's really broken and when it's
really broken people will come to
realize now we had we must do we have to
do something different we had a little
preview of that I think with both Ronald
Reagan to a certain extent and Margaret
Thatcher to a greater extent it will
probably require a a worst crisis than a
stagnation that Britain was facing or
the or Jimmy Carter now the other thing
the thing that makes me pessimistic
about this is that the older you get the
more you realize how little you ever
desire a crisis just how many people get
hurt in a crisis just how awful a crisis
is as a young imaginative and hopeful
kid it's sort of fun to say oh yeah a
big crisis and then everything will get
fixed you know won't that be fun
well crises don't turn out to be any fun
you know and
and and they do turn out to hurt a lot
of people but we'll probably we will
have to probably push our financial
system which is behaving extremely I
mean our government side of our
financial system it's you know very much
just printing worthless money in order
to pay for all this junk and we will
probably have to push it to the breaking
point before we realize you just can't
have everything and have it all for free
and but like I say you don't we at the
same time you know that this crisis has
to happen someday you sort of hope yeah
could that be after me thank you very
much thank you